cuando se cumplieron 65 años del fin de
la dictadura militar en Venezuela
cientos de trabajadores del sector
público y opositores marcharon en varias
ciudades para exigir al gobierno mejora
salariales ante una inflación disparada
y un salario mínimo de apenas seis
dólares al mes no sabemos si vamos a
comer Mañana no sabemos
[Música]
su honor a la casa de hambre o morir en
la calle luchando yo prefiero la segunda
opción luchar para que a los venezolanos
a los ciudadanos venezolanos se le
escuche que solo se le está pidiendo es
calidad de vida estamos pidiendo esto un
salario con poder adquisitivo la
contramarcha la lideraron los servidores
del presidente Nicolás Maduro que
también salieron a las calles de varias
ciudades para mostrar su apoyo al
oficialismo y en contra de las sanciones
económicas internacionales y
restricciones financieras especialmente
de Estados Unidos Que tocaban la
economía del país no pida sanciones que
se unan a buscar los recursos nuestros
nuestro oro que está en Inglaterra
nuestro dinero Venezuela se respeta un
pueblo aquí en la calle diciéndole que
resistimos que seguimos resistiendo y
que seguimos con nuestro presidente
Nicolás Maduro maduro quien canceló su
viaje Argentina y no asistirá a la
Cumbre Regional de la celac también se
reunió con sus seguidores hicieron ver
como que hoy 23 de enero
volvió en la guarimba
hicieron ver por las redes sociales
como que hoy 23 de enero arrancaba otra
vez un espiral de violencia Luciano
participar de la Cumbre el presidente
venezolano aseguró que respalda la
creación de una moneda común para
Suramérica como propusieron sus
homólogos argentino Alberto Fernández y
brasileño Ignacio Lula da Silva